bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on voit
maintenant après ces affrontements
israélo-palestinien au coeur de
jérusalem est on voit ces affrontements
entre l'armée isralienne d'une part et
le hamas d'autre part dans la bande de
gaza et aider des raids menés par israël
en représailles à des tirs de roquettes
à quoi doit-on s'attendre maintenant
écoutez je voudrais vous dire si vous
allez au cinéma cher penseurs et vous
arrivez pour voir les cinq dernières
minutes vous aurez du mal à comprendre
le film est exactement ce qui se passe
c'est à dire cette affaire cette
escalade dure depuis un mois
ça a commencé par des ratonnades comme
on disait pendant la guerre d'algérie en
france l'extrême droite
les ultra-orthodoxes criant mort aux
arabes cognant sur tout ce qui bougeait
ensuite on a eu le député fasciste
itamar ben gvir qui s'est agité pour
essayer d'accélérer le vol de treize
maisons palestiniennes
cheikh jarrah la police a été complice
et des ratonnades et de sept tentatives
de spoliation et elle est intervenue sur
l'esplanade y compris dans la mosquée al
aqsa où on a quand même c'est le
troisième de saint de l'islam tiraient
des gaz lacrymogènes n'imaginait qu'on
tire des gaz lacrymogènes devant le mur
des lamentations ou à notre dame
et donc c'est à ce moment là qu
effectivement leur hamas répond par des
tirs de missiles sur jérusalem est tout
cela coïncide pour tout arranger avec le
ramadan d'un côté et la fête des
israéliens pour l'annexion de jérusalem
est
donc si vous voulez on a quand même
toute une histoire qu'on ne peut pas
raconter par la fin alors que justement
le hamas
il faut quand même préciser que le hamas
ne reconnaît par refuse en tout cas de
reconnaître l'état d'israël est ce que
les événements qui ont précédé justement
les affrontements entre tsahal et le
hamas justifie les tirs de roquettes
depuis l enclave palestinienne sur
israël rien ne justifie rien et ça dure
depuis un siècle
c'est à dire qu'il y a deux peuples
une terre il faut trouver une manière
que les deux peuples
ils vivent à égalité soit chacun dans
son état soit dans un même état mais
avec une égalité je répète de droit ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que tout ça
ne vient pas par hasard ça n'interdit un
pas dans une ancienne serein ça
intervient à un moment où benyamin
nétanyahou a perdu quatre élections
échoué dans ses manoeuvres pour essayer
de de constituer malgré tout un
gouvernement avec des alliés islamistes
et fasciste il risque de perdre le
pouvoir après 15 ans d'expérience était
le plus long ministre de l'histoire
d'israël
et en plus il est orphelin de trump est
confronté à un nouveau président
américain qui est décidé à changer le
paysage du moyen-orient en particulier
avec le retour un d'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien et les négociations
avancent donc au fond netanyahu
c'est un incendiaire il veut mettre le
feu partout il veut mettre le feu à
jérusalem avec ses amis et d'extrême
droite
il veut mettre le feu dans le golfe je
rappelle qu'il ya eu des bombardements
de ton père irakien
le sabotage à deux reprises de la
centrale nucléaire de natal
tout est bon pour sauver ils sont encore
plus ans et il est encore influent
benyamin nétanyahou 1 parce qu'on sait
que ça y est relaté chargé de former un
nouveau gouvernement
300 police et le premier premier
ministre qui a duré aussi longtemps il a
une force politique réelle mais en même
temps il est en échec
et donc il profite surtout du vide il
n'y a pas de gouvernement israélien il
ya un gouvernement qui gère les affaires
courantes et il n'ya pas eu d'élections
palestiniennes et puisque mahmoud abbas
a décidé de les reporter donc on est sur
une poudrière poudrière qui est prête à
sauter et la politique de netanyahu
c'est de faire sauter la poudrière pour
essayer je répète de sauver son trône et
sa politique
alors vous dit ce qu'il attendait que
vous dites qu'il a perdu le soutien des
donald trump mais s'agissant justement
de de la communauté internationale si
l'on peut parler
ainsi mais des états unis surtout
l'administration maiden est un conte une
réunion en urgence du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et les états unis ont
opposé justement un nom à un document en
disant que le message était trop
prématuré pour l'instant donc à quoi
s'attendre
vis-à-vis des etats-unis moi je crois
qu'il faut être attentif à la motivation
américaine le veto américain ce n'est
pas une chose nouvelle sur ce genre de
dossier ce qui a été dit ce excepté pas
le moment d'en parler en public
est ce que nous savons nous les
journalistes qui avant quelques
informations du côté américain il serait
bien c'est que le ton monte en privé
baden a reçu le chef du mossad
il ya deux jours et il lui a passé un
savon pour dire les choses simplement en
disant maintenant ça suffit
ne saboter pas la politique de la
nouvelle administration américaine
l'union européenne s'inquiète et
j'ajoute parce que c'est mal compris
souvent que les états arabes les
dirigeants arabes se trouve dans une
situation de grand écart parce que d'un
côté ils sont en pleine normalisation
avec israël on le sait depuis le mois
d'août
mais d'un autre côté cette normalisation
elle ne passera pas dans leur opinion
si au même moment israël tente d'écraser
les palestiniens c'est pourquoi je crois
que le moment est venu pour la france de
se faire entendre
la france a une politique de plus
général de gaulle elle a été plus ou
moins appliquée disons plutôt moins que
plus dans la dernière période mais la
france peut dire et les membres du
conseil de sécurité membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité
elle a un rôle de leadership en europe
avec l'allemagne elle est écoutée dans
le monde c'est le moment qu'on entende
emmanuel macron ce qui est bizarre c'est
que c'est sans doute le seul chef d'état
au monde peut-être le groenland
je ne sais pas mais il n'y a pas eu d'
expression du président de la république
sur cette crise qui je le répète
n'en déplaise aux grands médias français
qui n'ont quasiment pas parlé jusqu'aux
tirs de missiles du hamas et dure depuis
un mois on verra répond l'union
européenne qui appelle tout de même à la
désescalade
israël dit avoir frappé son 30 cibles
militaires et tué 15 militants
à gaza dans la nuit comment justement
cela va évoluer dans les prochains jours
est-ce que ce conflit-là ouverts
actuellement il peu s'apaiser
je ne vous entend plus alors oui oui
comment le conflit ouvert peu s'apaiser
dans les prochains jours puisqu'il sera
elle dit avoir frappé 30130 cibles
militaires et tué 15 militants dans la
nuit à gaza
écouter durant l'été 2014
israël a bombardé pendant un mois et
demi a fait deux mille cent victimes
palestiniennes
une cinquantaine une soixantaine de
victimes israéliennes
on peut aller vers une explosion
généralisée et durable qui fut
d'ailleurs peut avoir des conséquences
au delà même de de cette région
donc c'est absolument capital que la
communauté internationale se fassent
entendre en public en privé peu importe
mais en tout cas qu'on l'entende qu'elle
pèse pour arrêter le bras des pyromanes
on a affaire vraiment à des pyromanes je
rappelle parce que ce sont des choses
qui ne sont jamais dit que le père de
benyamin nétanyahou était à l'extrême
droite de l'extrême droite sioniste dans
les années 20 et 30
une extrême droite qui a salué l'arrivée
d'hitler au pouvoir
le fils de netanyahu a offert son visage
pour une affiche du parti néonazi
allemand à fd et au milieu vous avez
netanyahu qui nous explique que hitler
ne voulait pas exterminer les juifs
franchement cette dynastie est une
dynastie de pyromane d'extrême droite et
il est temps que la communauté
internationale aide les israéliens et
les palestiniens à se débarrasser des
bouts de feu
c'est cela à mon avis bhl l'urgence de
l'heure et ils côté palestinien très
très rapidement quelle est la clé aussi
de l'apaisement est ce que les
palestiniens aussi le ramasse doit faire
des efforts bien sûr que le hamas doit
faire des efforts tout le monde doit
faire des efforts mais il faut bien
comprendre que la colère des
palestiniens
elle est légitime qu'elles qu'elles
s'expriment parce que on parle d'
escalade on parle de d'actes de guerre
on parle de bombardements
jusqu'à présent dès les centaines de
victimes civiles de blessés des hommes
des femmes des enfants ils sont pas
destinées 1 en très très très grand
nombre les victimes à gaza sont
palestinienne non on doit comprendre que
les palestiniens soit en colère ils ont
l'impression d'être abandonné abandonné
par la communauté internationale mais
aussi abandonnés par leurs propres
dirigeants
parce que la seule chose que mahmoud
abbas a trouvé à faire tout au long de
cette escalade
c'est d'empêcher des élections
démocratiques prévues d'avoir lieu
d'avoir lieu à la fois en cisjordanie à
gaza et à jérusalem-est merci beaucoup à
vous ne résisterez lien n'est pas donner
le coup de pouce nécessaire en
permettant facilement le vote à
jérusalem est c'est vrai que c'est un
problème majeur et enfin globalement je
ne comprends pas pourquoi le président
palestinien de l'espace on peuvent
s'exprimer choisir ses dirigeants quand
même la première fois depuis 2006 il y
aurait de l'élection merci à vous à
dominique vidal je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste historien auteur du
livre le moyen orient et le monde l'état
du monde 2021 aux éditions la découverte